Alright,
now I talked to you about these fingers
before and I was trying to make,
so here's,
here's kind of an overview of what
I'm attempting to describe to you.
So one,
there's one category of representation
that has to do with the territory that
you inhabit and that you understand
that's primarily social territory and it
tends to be symbolized by masculine
and usually like older male symbols.
So that's the patriarchal structure.
I really think what it is is a,
it's a personified representation of
the dominance hierarchy structure.
So,
um,
if remember the lion king,
you know the pride rock thing.
So the pride rock has sort
of associated with the,
with the symbols father.
And so that's,
that's that category of symbol is
the symbol that I'm talking about.
So he used that,
that high place on the mountain as
an indicator of dominance structure.
You saw that at the opening of the lion
king movie where all the animals come,
they gather around,
they all bow before the,
the rock with the king on top of it.
And the king,
like the lion is a symbol,
generally a symbol of something like
solar power because the lion is a top
Predator,
it's apex Predator and it
lives in Africa under the sun.
And it has a main that sort of like a son.
And then later in the lion king will
actually see this today you'll see the,
the Father Lion Mufasa,
yes,
he appears in the sky with
a solar halo around him.
So,
so that's the masculine category.
And then the feminine category I told
you a little about a bit about is a more
chaotic category and it's a,
it's a chaotic and plastic category
out of which new forms emerge.
And then one of the categories that we
haven't talked about is the category of
the individual and the individual is
the hero and hero stories and is the
initiate an initiatory routines.
And so the hero is the person who is
attempting to become a complete biological
and historical entity personality
so that they're capable not only of,
of,
um,
adopting independent existence,
but if adopting independent existence
that's productive and that's productive in
a way that's also a
benefit to the community.
So it's a particular pattern
of development and that
that needs to be catalyzed
by human societies because
in order for a society to,
to maintain its structure and for
the people within it to thrive,
the developing individuals have to mature
to the point where they can take care
of themselves in a way that doesn't
disrupt the whole social structure.
And so that's the path.
It's a natural path for human beings.
I would say to some degree,
because we're such
intensely social creatures,
but because we're also quite malleable
and complex and also grounded in history
and cultural creatures,
it's also something that has to be
taught both from the perspective of
invitation and explicitly.